hi i'm charlie heaton and i play
cannonball hi
i'm henry zaga and i play sunspot hi i'm
anya taylor joy and i play magic
hi i'm blue hunt and i play danny
moonstar hi i'm alyssia braga and i play
dr cecilia reyes
hi i'm maisie williams and i play rain
sinclair and together we are the new
mutants cast
and today we are going to take a
buzzfeed quiz and find out which new
mutants character we really
are
[Music]
how would your bffs describe you
creative
dedicated curious fearless cunning
or loyal it's hard to know how your best
friend you know i would say you're
creative buddy but you're loyal too
i don't know i don't know loyal henry is
very dedicated i mean yeah you're
dedicated my love
really take it dedicated it is oh my
gosh which one am i
creative yeah okay thanks loyal because
i'm an aries
i i would say loyal i would say annoying
but there's none
of them yeah maybe i'll go with creative
which subject was your favorite in
school science history art pe
english math art meets his english
history i did english and then i was
thinking about my english teacher senior
year
history i loved history yeah history
are we all history choose a superhero
movie
the dark knight wonder woman deadpool
avengers end game
birds of freya and the fantabulous
emancipation of one harley quinn
or x-men it's going to be the dog i'm
gonna get dark knight
now i am gonna go
with the dark knight
that was my picture the dark knight i'm
going dark night too
where would you want your secret
superhero hideout to be
a cabin in the woods a small suburban
town
a remote island or a highly populated
city
my island because there'd be like zero
crime
you wouldn't have to fight anytime you
i want to be in a city i want to be busy
so then he can fly
and save people and go back to the
island that's why i would say the beach
have you guys seen the incredibles when
they go to the island
i think i'm gonna go with a remote
island cabin in the woods doesn't sound
too safe i'm gonna go remote ireland i'm
gonna go highly popular
city just so i can fight crime which
abnormal superpower would you want to
have
ability to duplicate anything you touch
ability to teleport only two minutes
into the future
ability to step into any painting you
saw
ability to binge watch an entire tv show
in five minutes ability to make every
vegetable taste like ice cream
and ability to sing super well i'm gonna
go for painting
like mary poppins that sounds like so
much fun
into the future okay it doesn't sound
great but you know there's all those
times you're waiting you know there's
always those little two-minute wait
those things that really annoy you
think about touching things that and
make them duplicate
i think that's a pretty good one for
making some bank
i would love to step
into any painting i recently just got
into like impressionism
and like the colors are like
it's so tricky maybe the ability
to duplicate anything i touch i don't
know why i feel like that would come in
handy
not touching your breasts
i was between two but i think i would go
with the ability to sing super well
pick a tight-knit group of friends to be
part of the original avengers from
avengers
the starks from game of thrones
dumbledore's army from harry potter
scoops troop from stranger things the
friends
from friends and parks department from
parks and rec
i would have picked the stranger things
scoops troop if charlie was in it
but i'm a friends guy so i'm gonna go
with that one
so i'm gonna go dumbledore's army are
you thinking about being friends with
phoebe
no harry potter harry potter
obviously my people i
have to go with the scoob's troop from
stranger things they were so
funny those four together was like my
favorite thing of the entire last season
it made me laugh so much i'm definitely
dumbledore's army
i watched all of the harry potter movies
during my quarantine
i want to be a wizard you know now
that's
pretty cool i love action and i love
like being doing actions i think the
avengers would be fun because it would
be a lot of action
choose an x-men character to team up
with on a secret mission
jean grey storm professor x
wolverine magneto or mystique
obviously jean grey obviously like
there's no way for you to say something
else no
it'd be so shady if i did
i'm actually magneto i'm gonna have to
go with wolverine
because i'm in love with him and i'd
rather have that experience
he's my favorite x-men character
wolverine
i think wolverine would kick cast but
mystique would be really fun
i'm between wolverine and mystique so
you pick whichever one you want and i'll
go for the other one i think i'm gonna
hang out with jennifer lawrence on that
one
i got danielle moonstar i got daniel
i got roberto de costa yeah
i am sam guthrie
i got danny moonstar yay
i'm danny moonstar i always say that me
and danny
are the same i am fearless had strong
and tough
i'm extremely adventurous i'm beautiful
your personality matches you you are
curious observant and friendly
like sam you're someone who is very
aware of your surroundings and you are
a down-to-earth person you're a
natural-born
leader your personality matches roberto
you are popular
cunning and motivated your high
self-esteem is honestly your greatest
superpower
damn that's not me i think i think we're
supposed to do it like
more internally and pick correctly and
not be like you can take this one and
i'll take that one for fun
your personality matches danielle you're
headstrong fearless which allows you to
explore the world around you and try new
things with great ease you're ready for
anything life throws at you
you know what let's take it sounds like
thank you we've been the new mutants and
if you can don't forget to check out our
movie on the 28th of august
you